hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
one of the themes or if you like one of
the tropes or Expressions that we see
over and over again in the cynic
Epistles that are attributed to krates
the third skolarc of the cynic school is
this notion that cynic philosophy is a
kind of shortcut it is we might say
sometimes translated the Royal Road
meaning the road that's going on high
and not being obstructed by all sorts of
other things and so the shortcut or the
short path hotos is the word that they
use there for for road where that we
actually get method metoros from what is
it a shortcut too so sometimes it'll be
the shortcut within philosophy so it's a
shortcut in doing philosophy and getting
to what it is that philosophy is about
but it's also the shortcut to happiness
one of the things that philosophy is
supposed to provide us and we see this
figure or Trope coming up multiple times
within the exposition or advice that
karates is giving to his fellow cynics
and the people who might be attracted to
cynicism and cynicism by this time is
already becoming you could say not just
a school but a tradition and so in
letter six to his students
he says do philosophy more frequently
than you breathe for Living Well to
uzane which is what philosophy
accomplishes or what it produces is
preferable to Simply living which
breathing accomplishes and don't do it
as the others do philosophy so already
there's a distinction between how the
other schools how the other Traditions
are doing philosophy do what he says
as antistanies began
Eric Sato he started doing philosophy
this way and as diogenes the follower of
antistanies the teacher of karates as he
perfected it until the osei right
bringing it to its its fulfillment so
there's a clear Consciousness here that
antistanis is the founder but he only
brings certain things to the table and
diogenes takes what antistanies is
teaching putting out there and add some
other things and takes it to a higher
level so he says if doing philosophy in
this way is unpleasant at least it is
and here we have that Trope shorter
means short or brief quick it can be
used of like a discourse it can be used
of a travel a path and so this is at
least the shorter way of doing things
you'll find out that you know you're
suited for it or not and he closes by
saying as diogenes used to say one must
proceed towards happiness even if it's
through fire so the ascetic way of life
of the cynics here is likened to passing
through fire in letter 13 we again find
this this reference being made to the uh
the way of life of diogenes and they
talk about the cloak of diogeny so
cynics would wear a cloak and they had a
staff and a wallet what we would
nowadays call a backpack or a knapsack
so it says the cloak of diogenes is
disgraceful but secure here the one who
uses it is more trustworthy than other
people those who wear the Robes of the
carthaginians his life is simple but
healthier than that of the Persian his
way of life is toilsome but Freer than
that of sardinopolis now these are all
references that would make more sense in
a context that that he's writing in
suffice it to say what's going on in
each of these is that the cynic way of
life is something that imposes
requirements on you but it's going to be
better off than these other people so he
says if security is what you want Health
Freedom then philosophy that brings
about all these things is better too and
if it's not the philosophy of others
once again it is that of diogenes who
discovered the short road this shortcut
so Tom on hold on to happiness right and
then we get another really interesting
comparison here in in letter 19. you
know the cynics like some of the other
figures would Trace themselves back to
earlier legendary people that were
viewed as you know displaying the kind
of traits that they wanted
Odysseus is one Hercules was another and
so he's writing to patrol glaze and he
says
don't call
Odysseus the father of cynicism because
once he put on the Garb of a cynic the
cloak does not make a cynic the cynic
the cloak
instead called diogenes the father of
cynicism he put the cloak on not just
once but throughout his life he was
Superior to both toil and pleasure he
demanded his support but not from the
humble he abandoned all Necessities he
had confidence in himself he prayed he
might never attain to honors out of pity
but as a revered man he trusted in
reason and not in guile which Odysseus
is very known for or Bo his his uh
Warfare he was Brave not only at the
point of death but also courageous in
his practice of virtue emulate not
Odysseus but diogenes instead why not
Odysseus because Odysseus isn't a real
cynic at all he just acted like one at a
certain point so we've got some
interesting discussions here about this
tradition that is in the process of
development which karates himself is
Central to now we should talk about well
what is it that philosophy is supposed
to do it's supposed to bring us
happiness and freedom and virtue well
there's a few letters where they get
into the nitty-gritty of this and one of
these is early on letter five to his
students
he says that law is a good thing right
actually a beautiful thing cologne
but it's not Superior to philosophy
why
because law compels a person not to do
the wrong thing that's the way law works
it says you don't do this or we're going
to punish you
so it's you know the stick rather than
the carrot so to speak
philosophy teaches the person not to do
wrong right it actually instead of just
compelling them gives them some reasons
and he says to the degree that doing
something under compulsion is worse than
doing it willingly to that degree law is
worse than philosophy and he says do
philosophy don't take part in government
it's better to know the means by which
people are taught to do right than to
know the means by which they're
compelled to do wrong not to do wrong
and so what you see here is that the law
can't actually
get people to do the right thing because
they understand it and choose it it can
basically just keep them from doing the
wrong thing
but philosophy can help us see what the
right thing is and steer us towards it
so we we desire it for ourselves and we
do it for ourselves he's got another
interesting clarification that he
provides in letter 16 again to his
students uh he says that cynic
philosophy is diogeny and the cynic is
one who toils according to this
philosophy and once again to be a cynic
is to take a shortcut in doing
philosophy so don't fear the name or
Sean the cloak or wallet
um if you were good you you would not be
distressed at being called bad don't be
distressed even now in taking the
shortcut to philosophy even though other
people are going to make fun of you
they're going to call you a dog which is
what Kudos means right cynic
and he says all of this is merely
opinion
right doksa and doksa has kind of a
double meaning here so it does mean
opinion as like what a person thinks but
doesn't actually know and then shortly
after this he's going to say to be
enslaved and he's literally using the
word there for being a servant or a
slave dude
to be a slave to opinion and disgrace
now
in that sense what it means is
reputation your social status or lack of
social status or bad social status to be
enslaved to that
and and that to names mere shadows as
they say is most irksome
right so coming from halapos meaning
difficult
bothersome right it's not something that
you want if you're focused on what other
people are thinking you're gonna have a
rough time philosophy helps you not to
be enslaved to that sort of stuff and he
says despise these and other similar
things literally katafronen to look down
upon to think less of so that's that's
important in uh letter 18 he's going to
talk about
um
the cynic way of life and he says
something really interesting here
yourself to wash with cold water instead
of you know waiting for heated water or
nice lukewarm water to drink only water
as opposed to wine and all the other
things that you could to eat nothing
that has not been earned by toil to wear
a cloak to make it a habit to sleep on
the ground so this is the asceticism of
the cynics what is the payoff of this
well not only can you put up with a lot
of things but you still have access to
what's important the baths will never be
closed to you the vineyard and flocks
fail the fish shops and couch shops go
broke as they will to those who've
learned how to wash with hot water to
drink wine to eat without having toiled
to wear purple clothing and to rest on a
couch you will have everything that you
need if you've accustomed yourself to
simple living right and to earning what
what it is that you get in letter 29
there's a very important clarification
here about indifference he says it's not
because we are indifferent de foreign
the verb there to to not care about to
not differentiate it's not because we're
indifferent to everything that others
have called our philosophy cynic but
because we robustly endure those things
which are unbearable to them and why are
these things is unbearable to them
because of their weakness
or false opinion right the their
mistaken views about things and he says
it's for this latter reason and not for
the former they've called us cynics now
he's addressing this actually to his
wife hipparchia who is you know also his
student and he's saying you know this is
why people get mixed up about things we
don't actually display complete
indifference we just are able because of
our perspective to deal with things so
much better than other people who fail
complain try to get away from them there
are three specific letters too that I
think provide some very interesting uh
well-tailored advice so he writes to
metrolis who is his student and the
brother of hipparchia and he says so
long as you fear the names cynic I'm
going to call you by this name so
clearly Metropolis is kind of wavering
and you are still plainly afraid of it
you yourself address us as cynics and
you will learn how to do the other
things in this manner if you make it a
habit not to be afraid of words nor
merely to use them and then here he says
something about this path to happiness
the way that leads to happiness through
words is long
but that which leads through daily Deeds
is a shorter regimen right so that is is
a interesting thing and the word That
We're translating there is regimen
malate meaning like a occupation with
something care is another way or concern
uh so a shortened mode of being
concerned with one's own self and he
says the masses who desire the same end
as the cynics Freedom happiness you know
uh they flee from those who preach it
when they see how difficult it is and
then he says something really curious
here one must not become a cynic because
of this way but be born one now it's
actually a play on words so we should be
a little bit leery here about how strong
of a commitment this is
you're not becoming one right but
Guinness thigh to be born of that race
but we can see that through the the
regime through the work the assasis you
can become one but he does say the
regimen is more effective than the path
itself the path is behaving in a certain
way that's identifiable as you know
cynicism the actual practice is what is
important
to Ganymede and this may be to a
pseudonym since Ganymede was a famous
you know uh desired object of the Gods
he says so long as you fear the cloak
and wallet and staff and long hair and
as long as you love purple robes and
luxury you will not cease leading on
lovers as Penelope did her suitors and
you know it goes and says if you like
that if you're if you're cool with that
hey live that way all you want right but
if this is bothering you
become a cynic you're not going to have
to worry about people Desiring you
anymore after that he says put on the
weapons of diogenes with which he did
drive away those who had designs on him
rest assured none of the lovers will
ever approach you again why because
you're going to look like a bum you know
they're not going to be attracted to you
anymore and then finally to hipparchia
we have this kind of triumphant letter
he says we've got a kid I hear you know
you you were able to have a good birth
because of your cynic way of life your
exercise you're taking on Toil and then
towards the end he says
raise this child as a cynic let his bath
water be cold his clothes be a cloak his
food be milk Rock him in a cradle made
from a tortoise shelf this protects
against childhood diseases when he's
able to speak and walk dress him not
with a sword not as a warrior but with a
staff and cloak and wallet which guard
men better than swords and send him to
Athens and it closes on this very
interesting note as for the rest I shall
take care to rear a stork for our old
age instead of a dog so is he going to
be a cynic or not well we'll see but
he's saying you and I are cynics let's
raise our kid in this path to happiness
so the very important idea here that
cynicism is sort of the shortcut the
quick way to what philosophy ought to be
promising us namely a happy free
virtuous life